bleiben einmal noch in der Innenpolitik
und kommen zu Frau Gaschke und ihrer
These heute Abend in Ukraine Krieg
machen wir jetzt nicht auf aber wir
bleiben bei der Innenpolitik und ihrer
These naja was mich ja Dauer beschäftigt
ist irgendwie der Zustand dieser
Ampelkoalition und da ist sozusagen die
neueste spannende Umdrehung das jetzt
also der Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck verkündet hat und zwar
offensichtlich ohne seinen Amtskollegen
Christian Linda von der FDP auf dem
Finanzministerium auch nur zu fragen das
ist also keine Auswirkung auf den
Strompreis habe wenn die Atomkraftwerke
vom Netz gehen und das war ja noch nicht
die erste Runde in Sachen Atomkraft also
die Grünen hatten da ja auch eine
Beschlusslage und waren also es lag ihn
sehr viel daran dass man insgesamt
aussteigt also möglichst schnell es gab
einen anderslautenden Expertenrat also
verschiedene Experten haben gesagt mach
das in dieser Situation lieber nicht ihr
könnt erheblich sozusagen doch was
beitragen gegen die schlimme
Energieknappheit im Moment wenn ihr wenn
ihr die Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen
lasst dann ging das nicht wegen des
grünen Parteitages der das nicht Dul
heute hat man sich geeinigt zwei
Atomkraftwerke bis zum nächsten Frühjahr
dann brauchte es ein Machtwort des
Kanzlers nun also das dritte
Atomkraftwerk auch bis zum Frühjahr
laufen zu lassen in einer der schwersten
energiekrisen die wir je erlebt haben
und das ist natürlich sozusagen jetzt
ein Aufreger es ist aber im Grunde ja
nur ein Symptom für eine Koalition die
eigentlich überhaupt nicht zusammenpasst
was wir immer stärker merken und wir
also unsere Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
merken es auch also die zwei Drittel
finden sind sind sehr unzufrieden mit
der Arbeit der Ampelkoalition und
dreiviertel machen sich große unsere
oder sogar sehr große Sorgen um ihre
Zukunft alles Aktuelle umfragezahlen und
ich glaube man spürt da einfach man hat
hier zwei linke Parteien die die Grünen
und die SPD die im Grunde also mit
großen steuerfinanzierten
Ausgabenprogramm nach Problemen werfen
und zwar nach jedem Problem mit einem
weiteren Programm und eine FDP die
eigentlich von ihrer Grundausrichtung
her das Schulden machen das
inflationstreibende Schulden machen die
milliardenprogramme eher nicht sehen
muss und einen Christian Linder der das
also mühsam noch ausbalanciert bekommt
als Finanzminister ob er das auch zum
Teil natürlich mit Schattenhaushalten
und Sondervermögen ob er das im nächsten
Jahr mit der Schuldenbremse die immer in
der Verfassung steht noch hinbekommt ist
die Frage also da sind so viele
Sollbruchstellen drin in dieser
Koalition dass man und ich glaube so die
die Wähler spüren das klar wir haben das
jetzt alle irgendwie so zusammengewählt
aber es funktioniert nicht gut aber es
stimmt es stimmt dass die Bürger dass
das spüren auch in Umfragen herr Scholz
seid ihr als auch keine Grenzen
aber man fragt sich ja dann doch als
Bürger ich frage mich das immer wieder
warum bleiben die denn dann jetzt die
ganze Zeit zusammen also wären neue
Wahlen eine Option würde es Deutschland
dann besser gehen das ist eben die große
Frage und ich glaube die FDP sozusagen
es wäre Selbstmord wenn die FDP jetzt
auf einen Koalitionsbruch hinwirken
würde und das ist unser großes Dilemma
wir kommen aus dieser
regierungssituation im Grunde kaum raus
man sieht bei der FDP jetzt schon also
die ist ja zum Teil glaube ich auch ein
bisschen gewählt worden für ihre
standhaftehaltung in der corona-frage
haben sie jetzt da doch etwas weich
gespürt mit Lauterbach wieder
Kompromisse gemacht sie sie schmeißen
sich sehr ran finde ich bei der
Grünen rot-grünen Gesellschaftspolitik
das ist glaube ich auch nicht das was
ihre Kern Klientel aus Apothekern und
Hoteliers so super findet
folglich sind sie also jetzt schon in
Niedersachsen aus dem Landtag geflogen
in drei oder vier anderen
Landesregierung sind Sie auch nicht mehr
drin wir erinnern uns es ist ihnen im
Bund auch schon mal passiert nach der
Regierungszeit mit Frau Merkel zusammen
ich glaube die FDP wenn sie jetzt in
dieser Krisensituation mit Kriegsangst
energieangst und Corona immer noch nicht
ganz weg wenn Sie jetzt einen Bruch
herbeiführt und neu waren das wird ihnen
auch wieder keiner sagen ich habe
furchtbar an weil dann kommt der
eigentlich beim Bürger an die Partei ist
immer wichtiger als das Land und da ist
für die FDP das aus wäre werden die
sowieso in der Regierung bleiben ja aber
auf der anderen Seite finde ich muss man
ist auch politisch bewerten also das
kann man ja verstehen also dass die
jetzt eine und man muss vielleicht
fairerweise auch sagen also eine
Regierungskrise jetzt ein Wahlkampf in
dieser Situation
also davor kann man auch Angst haben
also man kann vielleicht vor dieser
Regierung etwas Angst haben aber man
kann sozusagen vor der neuwahlsituation
auch Angst haben und es ist ja ein
bisschen auch ein Problem der
alternativen also Friedrich Merz wird ja
in Umfragen also noch schlechter und
noch weniger fähig die Probleme zu lösen
eingeschätzt als Olaf Scholz und der ist
schon so unbeliebt also die Union
schafft es offensichtlich nicht sich als
eine starke Alternative sehr fragen wir
doch mal direkt bei Herr dohrendorf nach
ihr Parteivorsitzender Friedrich Merz
ist das ein guter Typ okay so also da
wäre Deutschland richtig weit vorne das
was hier gerade gesagt worden ist dass
man eventuellen Bruch hat das können Sie
völlig vergessen weil diese Politiker an
ihren Amt kleben an ihre Macht und an
ihren schwarzen Wagen und so lange das
da ist glauben Sie nicht dass die sich
in einer Legislaturperiode trennen auf
keinen Fall also diese können sagen nein
eh schon den schwarzen Wagen wegnehmen
ja das ist ja eine andere Geschichte ich
habe den Landwirten gesagt als sie hier
demonstriert haben ihr müsst eine Woche
das Ding Gedicht machen dass diese
schwarzen Autos nicht mehr fahren können
dann bewirkt er etwas
alle nicht fahren ja das ist ja völlig
egal aber wenn sie dann mit der U-Bahn
oder S-Bahn fahren
aber wenn man was bewirken will hier
dann muss man das halt so machen bei
ankleben stört bitte aber ankleben eine
Woche Traktoren mehr kein Problem ja so
ist das Friedrich Merz jetzt ist die
Chance hier dafür da Flammen genau
ich war Gegner der Frauenquote ja wir
haben jetzt so ein so ein ich sage jetzt
mal eine Geschichte nächstes Jahr 30%
dann 40% 50% und gucken uns zwei Jahre
an und dann schauen wir ob sich das ob
das etwas bewirkt hat oder nicht ich war
gegen die Frauenquote weil ich genug
Frauen kennen die wirklich richtig gut
sind und die junge Frauen in der CDU
waren auch dagegen ja
merken erst einmal die Partei wieder
geeint das muss man einfach mal sagen ja
hat hat viel ausgewechselt hat neue
Ideen reingebracht wir sind ja gerade
dabei das ein bisschen umzusetzen dann
müssen uns auch ein bisschen Zeit lassen
wir müssen es auch
Zeit ja vier Jahre und wir werden auch
Komposition der richtig annehmen und
wenn sie mal die die Debatten im
Parlament sehen dann waren die vom März
gegenüber Scholz und den ganzen Themen
wirklich sehr gut das muss ich einfach
so sagen wenn er dann halt bei den
Umfrage Geschichten nicht richtig
wahrgenommen wird da gehe ich auch mal
ein bisschen auf die Presse rein ja das
wissen wir ja auch aber finden Sie denn
dass die Union genug Druck macht also
kommt er genug aus der Opposition
Lösungsansätze die Opposition das war ja
vorher auch so bei den Grünen die haben
auch keine Lösungsansätze gebracht die
haben immer erstmal versucht den Finger
in die Wunde zu stecken das ist ja nun
natürlich auch mitregiert ja das war
eher das Problem aber hat man nicht das
Gefühl dass eigentlich Sarah Wagenknecht
die wahre Opposition in diesem Land ist
und nicht Friedrich Merz nein das habe
ich nicht den Eindruck sie hat sehr gute
Thesen ja ich habe geschmunzelt und Frau
Wagenknecht hätte ich auch nie gedacht
hat mir hat ein paar Sätze gesagt die
fand ich völlig richtig und das ist ja
auch okay wir haben sich heute als
wagenknecht-fan nein das würde ich nicht
machen ich bin ein ein Friedrich Merz
Fan das muss ich einfach sagen weil er
glaube ich auch ein bisschen Zeit
braucht um die die Schritte die ihr
jetzt die wir auch brauchen in der
Bundespolitik in der Bundes CDU jetzt
auch richtig umzusetzen
also auf mich wirkt er das orientiert
einerseits macht man diesen diesen
diesen
ja pseudo-fortschrittlichen Kram wie die
Frauenquote mit da hätte man doch
einfach sagen können das haben noch
andere Parteien nun lange genug
ausprobiert die sind nicht auch nicht
erfolgreicher damit also wir sind die
Partei die die 16 Jahre lang eine
Kanzlerin gestellt hat ganz ohne Quote
wir versuchen es mal auf einem anderen
Weg es ist ja keiner gegen
Frauenförderung ist ja nur die Frage ob
die Quote Intelligenz ist Instrument ist
und dann schmeißt er sich ran weil
irgendwelchen also vermeintliche
rechterin oder konservativeren Wählern
die er kriegen müsste um wieder
erfolgreich zu sein indem man sowas
unverantwortlich ist aus meiner Sicht
sagt wie also sozialtourismus und
ausgerechnet bei Flüchtlingen aus der
Ukraine das finde ich perfide und das
ist nämlich
gar nicht so gemeint und teilweise bei
die richtigen Fragen hat er das ja
gesagt er ist dann zurückgeholt hat sich
dafür auch entschuldigt ja und dann
frage ich mich wo ist da das
Koordinatensystem ich glaube wo wir eine
echte repräsentationslücke haben ist
tatsächlich ein bürgerlich konservativen
Bereich also die Leute denen diese ganze
Identitätspolitik und der ganze
verbotskram auf die Nerven gehen das
könnte ja das Gendern das könnte die
Union sein aber aber März repräsentiert
das noch nicht richtig und das Problem
ist natürlich die AFD hat sozusagen
Platz rechts von der CDU weggenommen und
Platz für eine Neugründung weggenommen
also da kriegt man jetzt nicht so leicht
noch irgendwas dazwischen aber man hat
die repräsentationslücke und die ganzen
Wähler gehen doch einfach erstmal in die
Nichtwahl in Niedersachsen haben sie 45%
glaube ich sehe ich das auf NRW waren 45
% nicht wieder Niedersachsen war auch
nicht viel besser und da ist die Frage
wo kommen die hinterher wieder raus das
ist echt gefährlich fürs politische
intern war das eben ein Thema diese
schaufensterpolitik die in vielen
Bereichen Enttäuschung war müssen sie
doch klar wir haben uns mehr erwartet
ganz klar und aber das ist eben so das
sind halt dass das passierte halt so und
dann verlieren wir und wir müssen jetzt
halt wir haben ja nun auch völlig alles
umgekrempelt sind ja gerade dabei wir
haben neuen Fraktionsvorsitzenden wir
sind gerade dabei die Ausschüsse zu
gründen wir versuchen
ja aber auch Personal nicht ganz
unwichtig ne das haben wir gerade eben
beim März gesagt und ich glaube es ist
auf dem guten Weg wir müssen nur das
Problem ist halt immer wenn man immer
erstmal den Umfragen fragt und schaut
kommt das gut an dann ist es einfach
falsch das ist diese diese
schaufensterpolitik diese Mainstream
Politik die ich nicht mag und da hätten
wir uns viel eher auch bei Merkel schon
Absenden müssen das haben wir nie
gemacht
dass wir dass wir unsere Leute
eigentlich nicht im konservativen
einfach verloren haben also Klartext
Politiker wie sie in der ersten Reise
ich nicht ja fehlen aber sie kommen ja
nicht weiter ne also wir haben sie nicht
nein ich folge ja nur mein inneren
Kompass und dann sind sie halt nicht der
den man will sondern man möchte halt
dann Leder leider Gottes immer der der
immer sagt ja das hast du echt toll
gemacht super du bist ein ganz toller ja
und das bin ich eben nicht sondern man
muss heute auch ganz klar wenn man kein
ja Sager ist hat man es in der deutschen
Politik schwer in dem Fall ja das war
schwierig das auf jeden Fall das auf
jeden Fall für Landesvorsitzender des
Ausschusses Internet und Medien bei der
FDP in Hamburg und ich habe mich
kritisch geäußert gegenüber dem NDR und
Zeit später hat Katja Suding meinen
Ausschuss gestrichen und mit dem
Innenausschuss zusammengelegt und hat
mich dann drei Wochen später Anrufer
gesagt haben es tut mir leid wir haben
vergessen dir das zu sagen aber du
kannst zum Innenausschuss gehen da ist
jetzt deinen Ausschuss vor Ort welche
Gründe auch immer das gehabt haben mag
so funktioniert das bei ihnen kam ganz
klar an wer Missstände anspricht fliegt
raus
würde ich in diesem Fall tatsächlich
sagen es war 2013/14 in der Zeit und das
jetzt schon ein bisschen her aber die
Zeit vergeht ja sehr schnell und ich
kann das nur so erinnern ich habe viele
Sachen in der Kreis- und Landespolitik
gesehen wo ich sage damit möchte ich
eigentlich nichts mehr zu tun haben da
komme ich auch zu meinem Punkt denn wir
reden ja eigentlich über die
Energiekrise und über ich glaube die
Atomkraftwerke die an aus an aus und so
weiter über diese Frage und was mich am
meisten stört daran an genau dieser
Sachen dass dieses Wort Energiekrise so
auftaucht und eine Krise ist für mich
ein Zustand der quasi schicksalhaft über
einen hinein hereinbricht und ganz
ehrlich ich glaube diese Sache dass wir
wenig also wenn Energiemangel haben die
ist ja kein Schicksalsschlag des
Universums sondern ich würde eher sagen
da hat jemand gesagt wir wollen keine
Energie mehr aus Russland haben und
welche Gründe auch immer dafür
vorherrschen man kann dann aber die
nachfolgenden Zustände nicht
Energiekrise nennen Energie an ja wer
auch immer den zugedreht hat man hat
zunächst gesagt man will diese Energie
nicht mehr haben das hat ja Frau wie
heißt sie noch Frau bärbock hat das
gesagt ich bin nicht so in der Politik
ich beobachte die ich weiß wie sie alle
aussehen und so weiter aber die hat ja
nun ganz klar gesagt wir wollen diese
Energie auch für immer nicht mehr haben
und da kann ich nur sagen wenn der
energiehahn zu ist und man sagt dann ist
es eine Krise dann hat man vorher ja
irgendwie keine Alternativen gehabt das
heißt also die mangelage ist jetzt
erstmal da zum Beispiel Energie Krieg
genannt indem wir uns befinden ja wenn
wie gesagt ich kann immer nur sagen wenn
man nach irgendwohin ruft und sagt ich
will das nicht mehr haben und dann auf
einmal hat man es nicht mehr egal ob da
jemand zugedreht hat und man hat sie ja
vorher gesagt dann gibt es keinen Krieg
sondern dann hat man das ist die
Kinderwelt von der aber man hat sich ja
auch willentlich und wissentlich
abhängig gemacht von Russland also und
von von russischen Energielieferung und
es gleichzeitig aber das ist ja eine
sehr schnell aber es ist ja keine Krise
es ist ja eine aktive Entscheidung also
das verstehe ich sozusagen was Sie damit
sagen
Fehlentscheidungen und es ist eben
draußen ist ich weiß ja wie Menschen
haben ja ein feines Gespür für viele
Dinge das merke ich ja auch mit meiner
Arbeit die ich Sachen Corona mache aber
ich merke das natürlich auch bei der
Frage der Energiekrise es ist keine
Krise sondern es ist ein politischer
Wille der jetzt umgesetzt wird egal von
welcher Seite der kommt aber es gibt
keinen Mangel der das ist ja nicht so
dass auf der Welt ein Mangel an Energie
herrscht sondern die Energie die wir
vorher hatten welche Umstände auch immer
dazu geführt haben dass das jetzt die
benutzen wir jetzt nicht mehr und
dadurch haben wir wahrscheinlich eine
mangelage noch haben wir sie nicht
vielleicht wird sie auch nur vorgezeigt
vielleicht klappt das ja auch alles man
weiß es nicht es ist ja vielleicht auch
gar nicht schlecht man weiß es ja nicht
was dabei am Ende rauskommt aber es ist
so eine Welt die nicht ausprobiert ist
und wo jetzt meines Erachtens ganz gut
passt dass eine kindliche Welt sich dann
auch existiert die sagt ja wir gucken
mal was passiert das ob man das mit
Hunderten von Millionen Menschen so
machen kann weiß ich nicht das ist ein
großes Experiment auch da wieder und
deswegen sage ich kindliche Weltsicht
ist gefragt die Leute mögen das nicht
und im Winter wenn es kalt wird werden
die möglicherweise auf der Straße
auftauchen dann werden Sie nicht nur
wegen Corona auftauchen da waren ja auch
schon 100.000 auf der Straße sondern
dann werden Sie vielleicht auch wegen
der Mangellage an Energie auf